in an energy sector in crisis this is
the darkest moment so far
with 1.7 million customers and a
commitment to supplying 100 renewable
power bulb energy should have been a
shining light
but as sky news revealed today the
company now stands on the brink of
collapse
for bulb customers like john cursop the
collapse means further pressure on
increasingly strained household budgets
the worst time possible really coming up
to winter temperatures dropping what
last couple of days and now you're
suddenly
left in the dark so we say if i decide
to work from home then obviously it's
gonna be cold the winter you're gonna
want the heating on um and you don't
know how it's gonna cost you in the long
run and if i didn't decide i'm going to
work from the office
um
price of fuel going up so much so you're
going to lose lose a little situation
really
a global squeeze on the supply of
natural gas has seen at least 20
suppliers go bust since august but until
now ministers have refused to step in
in a statement bolb said
we've decided to support bolt being
placed into special administration which
means it will continue to operate with
no interruption of service or supply to
members if you're a bold member please
don't worry as your energy supply is
secure and all credit balances are
protected
did you hear bulb is the biggest green
energy company bulbs collapse will mean
that nearly four million british
households have seen their energy supply
going under since the summer
so two things have happened one is that
wholesale energy prices particularly gas
currently around about four times their
normal levels that's of course a huge
shock to the energy supply market uh and
secondly though we are seeing a lot of
companies which were frankly woefully
under-capitalized being hit by this
shock and going bust and only the really
strong companies will survive
the company had been talking to bigger
industry rivals for weeks about a rescue
deal but last-ditch plays for a
government-sponsored solvent bailout
were rejected
bulb's size means that hundreds of
millions of pounds of taxpayers money
will now be put at risk to run the
company while a buyer is sought for its
assets and i understand that bulbs main
creditor has been demanding that the
government repays a 50 million pounds
loan made to bulb before it crashes into
administration
the administration is likely to be
formally confirmed this week
bulb won't be the last energy company
for which the lights are turned off for
good
mark kleinman sky news